[موسيقى]
لدينا 32c أو السينما المماطلة
ونود استخدام ذلك لأنني تقريبًا أحب
ليلة التاريخ التي نشتري فيها الفشار والحلوى
ثم نجعلها وكأنها تجربة
كما لو كنا جميعًا نحبها
[موسيقى  ]
نبقى نشيطين للغاية
في وظائفنا ومسؤولياتنا اليومية ،
أعني التجول في جميع الغرف
والتأكد من تثبيت حالة البخار هناك ،
فنحن نقوم بالكثير من
التعقيم فقط للتأكد من أن
كل شيء نظيف ولكن ما نفعله أيضًا
هو  نتجول إلى كل شريط من كل
يوم نقوم فيه بتدفق الفراغات ، ونترك المياه تتدفق
في Finks وفي الصندوق
والاستحمام فقط للتأكد من أن
كل شيء يتدفق ويعمل
بشكل صحيح
إلى
غرفة أخرى ثم نسيان ما إذا كنت قد فعلت
ذلك قبل أن نختبر جميعًا ،
فكر في ذلك مع 160 غرفة
وغرف نوم أعتقد أنه من المهم من
وجهة نظر الإدارة وأيضًا
لوجهة نظر المجتمع أن القلعة
كانت موجودة  بدا  بعد كل الأوقات
الآن ، سيكون من السهل جدًا المضي قدمًا ، فنحن
نغلق Shore لدينا
عامنا الثامن عشر المضمون ، لكن من المهم
للمبنى كعلامة احترام
للمبنى كما قلت إنه كان
هنا منذ 800 عام
[موسيقى]
أنت
كم مرة يمكنك أن تقول إنه إذا
أتيت وأقمت في قلعة في
أيرلندا ولدينا هذه الهالة السحرية حولها
، يأتي الناس ويقولون ليومين إنه
شيء تراجعه بعد ذلك  لا
تغادر العقار ، لدينا كل شيء
هنا يمكن أن يستوعبك لفترة من
الوقت أثناء تواجدك هنا معنا ،
سنرى جميع منافذ تناول الطعام
أيضًا ، لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أن الأمر يتعلق
كثيرًا بالموظفين الذين
لدينا موظفين كانوا هنا
منذ 40 عامًا ، وكانت هناك عائلة ناضجة جدًا ،
وهي ضيافة أيرلندية تقليدية جدًا ،
فنحن الآن جاهزون في مكان الإقامة
للترحيب بالضيوف مرة أخرى في الثاني من يوليو
، لقد تلقيت العديد من المكالمات الهاتفية
للحجوزات  الآن في هذه المرحلة وأعني من
الواضح أننا ذاهبون إلى  يجب أن
تمتثل لك ، تعرف معايير التباعد الاجتماعي الجديدة
ولوائح السلامة
التي سيتم وضعها ولكننا
لا نريد أن نستبعد حقيقة
أن هذا من المفترض أن يكون في مكان ما حيث
يأتي هؤلاء الضيوف للحصول على تجربة
مذهلة  تجربة والاستمتاع
[بالموسيقى]
كما تعلم بمجرد انتهاء ذلك ،
سنعود إلى الندوة عبر الإنترنت التي تعرفها في
شقتنا المكونة من غرفة نوم واحدة ، لذا يتعين علينا جميعًا
أن نتعود على ذلك أيضًا ،
لكننا سنفعل ذلك.  سوف نعتبر الأمر كما لو كنت
في قلعة بالطبع تريد
قصة خرافية أو أي شيء ، وضد
هذه هي الطريقة التي يجب أن
ننظر بها إلى هذا كما تعلمون أننا قضينا
وقتًا رائعًا معًا ولدينا  تعلمت
الكثير عن وظائفنا ولكن الكثير عن بعضنا
البعض كزوجين ، لذا فأنت تعلم أنه يوجد
دائمًا في أوقات التفكير هذه
التي يمكن أن يأتي منها الكثير من الناس على
حق ،
وقد أتى الكثير من الخير منها